senator chuck grassley sir thanks for
joining us
on this very busy very important
saturday we appreciate it
um lots of activity uh
over there on capitol hill this weekend
i had an old boss who used to say to me
don't confuse activity for output so my
question to you sir is does any of the
speechifying
and the meetings going on this weekend
impact the outcome
the end goal for monday no it'll be 51
49
to 48 and we know that right now and it
would be a good thing
if senator schumer would let us vote
right now
and then use the rest of saturday sunday
and monday
to talk about the covid legislation
that they won't let us bring up as a
vote earlier this week
i think it's a great week that we're
having a great weekend we're having in
the sense of
getting the third supreme court justice
under president trump president trump
promised that
the type of people he's going to put on
the supreme court and
this is the third one of that type what
you might call a strict constructionist
as opposed to what democrats normally
put on
uh justices that like to legislate and
and things like that so it's a great day
and you heard from my
colleague senator ernst she's here this
weekend
working on it as well and it is an
extraordinary session but
to get ninth justice on it's very
important that we do this
so if this goes according to your plan
and amy coney barrett gets confirmed or
gets pushed through the entire senate
monday she will do so
along a party line vote as you yourself
mentioned sir it's going to be a first
in history we know
you and your republican colleagues would
rather take it than leave it so
this is the best you're going to do
right now but do you feel good about
that do you feel
good about the precedent that it sets
going forward into the future to have
not a single member of the opposition
endorse your candidate well we had the
same vote for kavanaugh as you know and
i think we had the same vote for gorsuch
uh it's so it's a little different if
you have a republican president
if you have a democrat president like we
did with
the two democrats that like sotomayor
and
kagan that the previous president put on
a lot of republicans voted for them
but i think democrats feel a little more
comfortable being very
very partisan about it as opposed to
republicans
because so to my error and kagan got a
lot of republican votes when we had a
democrat president
and even some of those times we had a
democrat senate
yeah fair point so former vp
joe biden says that if he wins in
november he's going to appoint
possibly a special commission to look
into adding justices to the bench what
we colloquially
refer to as court packing
what are your thoughts about that well
we've had nine justices
for 150 years there's been times
that we've had less than nine justices
and uh and i think that that it's their
way
or it'd be biden's way of satisfying the
sander
sander easter's you know the progressive
wing of his party
who are demanding this uh to put a 10th
11th 12th and 13th member on the supreme
court because they
they want a majority that i described as
people that are judicial activists
uh people that want when there's a void
in a 50-year-old law let's say well the
supreme court ought to put it in
well that's a big difference between
barrett and a lot of
people that democrats put on the supreme
court because she said my job
is to interpret law not to make laws so
if there's something that you don't like
about the statute
don't come to the supreme court to get
the void filled in
let congress do what congress is
supposed to do legislate that's the
checks and balances of government
so sir i get your point which is that
adding justices
would certainly move us in a direction
towards
potentially politicizing the court if
the government majority is free to add
justices as they want to going forward
it sets a precedent that not a lot of
folks are comfortable with but on the
other hand
democrats point out nothing in the
constitution that prevents us from doing
it and republicans
through the process of rushing through
supreme court justices has brought us to
this place where the rules are now
we will do whatever we can no holds
barred
well that's where that's where this
election all comes about
with uh senator schumer let's say
putting in
200 million dollars in iowa to beat joni
ernst because he wants to take control
of the united states senate
and he says everything is on the table
packing the supreme court is one of the
things that are on the table
also doing away with the 60 vote
requirement in the united states senate
so that they can do things in a partisan
way
today the senate is the only institution
in our
political system that forces
bipartisanship because 53 republicans
can't get anything done
unless i'm talking about legislation now
not judges
but you can't pass a bill unless you got
bipartisan support for it
and if you like bipartisanship
you've got to keep the 60-vote
requirement in the united states senate
senator thank you for your time for
taking time out on what is a very
important day for you and your
colleagues on capitol hill we wish you
the best and we
hope to have you back soon thank you sir